пані та панове я говоритиму
російській мові
загалом присутній російською
делегації вже порушує ці основні
принципи
задекларовані під час створення за годиною
це безпека
економічне співробітництво та як було
сьогодні сказано це примирення
і ні
Але саме держава Росії визнана
ще кілька днів тому на головному
форумі
світлових держав ООН визнала Росію
тримала терорист
особливий цинізм викликає те, що серед
учасників
делегації з Росією присутня
військовий злочинець
Шеремет Михайло, який представляє
який організував
угруповання яке називають ополченням
на руках який насильство вбивство
наших громадян у Криму Я вважаю
що всі делегації
[музика]
Ні я вважаю що ми тут
почав державу
порушило кримінальні справи І я точно знаю
через деякий час
члени цієї делегації сидітимуть
підсудних і я та інші
громадяни України свідчать
проти їхніх звірств
і останні
проти Людини
тут не тільки не закон, а й воно
протиріч
[музика]
завдання наша організація